earlier this week derek carr
had his name come up uh in a well not
directly but indirectly in an item
written by his brother david carr
because russell wilson has flagged the
raiders as one of the four teams to
which he'd accept a trade david carr in
an nfl.com article said that any of
those teams
to which wilson would accept the trade
should have called about a trade for
wilson yesterday indirectly and
inadvertently throwing derrick under the
bus the article by the way was quietly
revised to remove that reference to any
of the four teams in order to try to
undo some of the damage the damage was
done and mike mayok the gm of the
raiders had a chance to do some damage
today to the relationship with derek
carr here's mayok talking about the guy
who they apparently believe for now is
their franchise quarterback
i think derek carr had his best year yet
under john gruden
i i think he's one of the top
quarterbacks in the nfl and we couldn't
be happier with them and i tell you
every year i mean we evaluate every
position every year i have no idea who
can who who might call me or who might
not call me so you have to do the
evaluations both on your own players and
every other player in the league and
you've got to stack your boards and
understand what league value is all
around the league and we do that
but if you're asking me about derek i
mean i think john and i would both stand
shoulder to shoulder and pound the table
for dark car
okay we'll pound the table for derek
carr but you know we don't know who's
going to call or who's not going to call
i
there's still that sense of
if we can get an upgrade over anyone
that we currently have and it makes
sense for us we're going to do it and
that is the
the ruthlessness of professional sports
all sports
football baseball basketball hockey
soccer whatever
if you you're not employing people that
you like people you want to hang out
with people who are your friends that's
how you get yourself into trouble you
have to be willing
if the opportunity arrives
in a minute to say to a guy who's been
with you whether it's one year 10 years
or somewhere in between that you believe
is going to be with you indefinitely see
you later we have an opportunity to get
somebody better and we think we're able
to do it for a fair value so
even though the headline is they'll
stand shoulder to shoulder and pound the
table for derek carr there's enough
there shireen from mike mayok to not
change anything he said the past couple
of years about constantly looking for
upgrades at all positions and
i i you know some players may be
upset
to know that but it's the truth at least
he's being honest at least he's not
lying to players and acting like they
have a lifetime pass they don't the
minute they they find somebody better
you're gone
and there's not that many players mike
who are off limits in the nfl but this
quarterback cycle over the last two
years i i can't remember anything like
it when every almost every team is
looking for an upgraded quarterback i
mean we went through this of teams
committed to their quarterback in the
quarterback committed to the team and
there's just not that many and it's
amazing because used to we would see
quarterbacks even if they didn't quite
make it like a sam darnold for a few
years they get a few more years right
well we're almost there we're almost
there we just gotta get a little bit
more talent around him and and they
would pass on quarterbacks in the draft
and think they could upgrade with the
talent around him and all those sorts of
things now we're just starting to see
teams just go okay i'm going to get me
an upgrade at quarterback and you know
derek carr has done some great things
you know he's
had three straight pro bowls 15 16 and
17 earned mvp votes
in 2016 when they went 12-3 but that was
their only winning record the only time
he's ever had a winning record in a
season he has no postseason starts i
couldn't think it took me a minute to
think of connor cook the year he started
the playoff game because derek carr was
was hurt that year so he's been good but
he hasn't been good enough mike he would
be a upgrade for some teams
but the raiders want an upgrade on him
and to me there's only
you know a handful of guys in the nfl
that would be an upgrade on derek carr
at this point so i'll be curious to see
what happens at the raiders russell
wilson certainly would be one of those
guys who would be an upgrade but you got
to give a ton of compensation for him
a handful of guys it must be some like
alien hand that has like 12 fingers on
it
okay a couple of hands more than five 10
maybe 10 15 somewhere in that range but
there's not a ton i mean sam darnold's
not an upgrade some of the guys who are
there who would be available i don't see
his upgrades
russell wilson is and and look here's
the bottom line no doubt
bears saints cowboys rape cowboys
raiders are all on notice and have been
for six days now that russell wilson is
interested in them and it would be
stupid to think
that these teams haven't
run the numbers worked the angles maybe
even called the seahawks to see what it
would take to get russell wilson how can
you not do it you know when mayhawk says
you never know who's going to call you
also never know whose agent is going to
declare publicly
that one of the best quarterbacks in all
of football
is going
to accept the trade to your team so you
make the call at that point and just say
hey yo look what's really going on here
john let's talk about this i want to
make sure we don't miss an opportunity
to help both of us
are you interested in derek carr could
we work something out let's just talk it
through off the record you and me and
if if they didn't do it then they're
stupid it's stupid to think they didn't
and if they didn't then they're stupid
yeah i agree with that completely
russell wilson certainly is an upgrade
on derek carmen he's won his super bowl
started in another super bowl he's been
outstanding even though he has fewer mvp
votes than derek carr we know how that
thing works so he has been better and he
would be better and he would lift up the
raiders and if they're looking to trade
we heard today you know trent brown may
be on the market some of those guys hey
that would be compensation for for the
seahawks who obviously need to upgrade
their offensive line we've heard that
from russell wilson that they need so
there's some players there that they
certainly would be willing to give up
and take an awful lot of compensation
but if you're the raiders you're john
gruden you have to make that phone call
we know what john gruden thinks of
veteran players anyway so you build
russell wilson around with veteran
players instead of those rookies coming
in to play for you you're just going to
lose those draft picks for a while but
he can get you over the hump mic with
this roster if you keep most of this
roster intact
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports